Çok teşekkür ederim Hani deniz ya her
şeyin başı sağlık O yüzden sizlerle olan
konuşmama sağlığı seçmek istedim şimdi
çok teşekkür ederim Çok kötü annemden
geçiyoruz altıma gün dünyada 110000000
üstünde insan hastalandı milyondan fazla
insanı kaybettik Türkiye'de Yaklaşık 3
milyon gidiyor hasta sayımız
kaybettiğimiz insan sayısı 30000 üstünde
izin hesaplarınız doğrudan ve dolaylı
olarak ülkemizde 100 bin civarında
insanı annemin elinde kaybettik gibi
Antep'ten çıkış yolumuzdur aşılar yani
yaşayan herkese sağlık sıhhat verecektir
çözümü içinde barındıran bugün
itibariyle dünyada 111c aşılama aletine
girişte başla
bu dünyada 60 milyon insan iki dos
yaparak onları koruma altına almayı
başardık başarımı kere 2 milyon
civarındaki insan kuruluyor 7 buçuk
milyar 80 milyon 1 başla önemlisi Bunlar
şansına sahip ülkeler 111 yani dünyadaki
ülkelerin sadece 150s geri kalan 140
milyar insan herhangi bir girişimde de
yani olanlarda da birleşik Amerika
Birleşik Devletleri'nde günde iki
milyondan fazla dolaşıyor Amerikan
toplumunu nüfusunun yüzde yetmiş kişinin
üstüne süresi 6 ay
e Devlet'ten de altı ayda herkes komik
19'dan korunacak Türkiye'de 600 günde
arada 4,3 yılda Türkiye ye göre dört kat
daha eşitsiz sekiz buçukta eşitsiz bugün
İsrail'de yaklaşık üç buçuk milyonu
Aşkın kesim insan konuyor toplulukla
karşı nedeniyle İsrail nüfusuyla
Türkiye'nin nüfusu orantı london'da
İsrail'de Aşık korumasını ulaşmış insan
sayısı ülkeye göre 16 kat daha fazla
Türkiye'de yaşayan Bizler İsrail'de
yaşayan insanlara göre 16 Kat daha az
bir malı verileri dünyanın gelen yaşayan
insanların kirlenmiştir USA göre aşağıya
o şansını değerlendirdi deposuna yüzüne
aşırı ulaştırabilmek şansına sahip
Dünyada sadece 43 olduğunu bunların
38'de zengin ülkeler olur bir sırayı
Kanada çekiyor nüfusunun altı kat kadar
açıklayabilmiş durumda sırada Amerika
İsviçre geliyor ve 5 katı kadar bu 43/2
arasında ya nüfusunun tamamına aşağı
garantisini sağlayan ülke arasında
ülkede tamamen ceplerindeki paraya göre
bir eşitsizlik sınıflamasında nüfusunun
hemen hemen hiç birine aşık Garanti
sağlayamamış kamboçya'da her yaşayan bir
insandan sadece üçünü aşağı ulaşacağız
Kanada'da ulusunun 6
Evet bohçada her bi insandan 3'ü
aralarındaki eşitsizlik farkı 2149 18
Ocak'taki Dünya Sağlık Örgütü Başkanı O
Gün itibariyle 49 yüksek gelirli ülkede
39 milyon Aşkın insanı aşı yapıldığını
ana gelini bilince sadece 25 doz aşının
başladıkları bu değil 25 milyon değil
sadece 25/9 veya sağlık kurulu başkanı
olan tecrübeli ahlaki çöküş olduğunu
söyledi bir sadece kişisel bireysel
ahlaki bir çöküş müdür aşka düşünmek
lazım altıncı 17 Şubatta Birleşmiş
Milletler Genel Sekreteri dedi ki on
zengin ülke aşılara yüzde yetmiş beşini
her koydu Dünya nüfusunun yüzde onundan
daha azını yaşadığı 10
bu hastaların etmesinler yani yarısından
fazlasını yaptı 130'dan fazla ülkede tek
bir dolaşıyor bu tarafta bu dünya
nüfusundaki yüzde onundan daha az nüfusu
barındıran zengin geliyor yani dünyadaki
açlığın yüzde yetmiş beşi ne el koyan
zengin Yenice başlıyoruz Şimdi artık
için yardım yardım insanların Sağlık
hakkı ortada dururken ve bu zengin
ülkeler insanların aşı haklarını
ellerinden alırken kendi vicdanlarını
rahatlatmak için 7 buçuk milyar sadaka
benzeri yardım yapmalarını nasıl kabul
edeceğiz sorunlar var
Ama gerçekten yaşadığımız sorun Dünya
Sağlık Örgütü'nün başkanın dediği gibi
bireysel Deveci bir ahlaki çok düşme
yoksa adına Kapitalizm dediniz aradan
başka hiçbir değeri görmeyen sistemin
insanlığı artık sistem ile karşı karşıya
kimsesizlik sağlıkta Birkaç çeşit
olabilir doğaldır kadınlarda erkeklerden
daha fazla görülür değildir kadınların
fazladır Onlar da bu hastalığın
görülmesi doğaldır bir sağlıkta bunların
tartışıldığı ve eşitlikten bahsetmiyoruz
doğal biyolojik bir eşitlikten
bahsetmiyoruz yaşadığımız sorun
uygarlığın yani toplumun Yani biz
insanlığın var ettiği o kutsal bir
eşitsizlik halinden
de diyebilirsiniz ki annemin çok gene o
yüzden aşılar yeterli üretilemiyor 7
buçuk milyar insan ulaşabilecek dolu da
aşağı üretemiyoruz hayır doğru değil
bugün Eğer izin verilirse dünyanın
farklı ülkelerindeki haklı yapılar 7
buçuk milyar insanın şimdi ne Aşık
üretebilecek geliştirdik neden izin
veriliyor Çünkü firmaları Annem
haklarını ellerinden tutarak
kendilerinden başka kendilerinin
fabrikalarından başka hiçbir yerde aşure
bilmesini istemiyorum Agent Çağrı
Kazancı önceleyen bir süreçtir sağlığın
gözardı edildi milyonlarca insanın ölüme
terk edildiği bir ortamda firmalar
firmaları A çok duyduğumuz fazla modern
Aa bak kendi kararından vazgeçme öyle
bir dünyada yaşıyoruz O yüzden 13e Işıl
onun yüzde yetmiş beşi Ne koyu
Sen Bensiz olmaz mı gerçekten mümkün
değil mi Bizim derdimiz o kadar güzeldi
ki öyle çocuk felci aşısını bulan Kaşif
olan kalk aşırı paketlenecek misiniz
milyar dolar kazanabilirsiniz cümlesinin
karşına birleşik patent diyebilir
misiniz Bu insanlar hiçbir şeydir
insanlığa ettirmiştir önce açısını
terlemedi yüzden milyonlarca çocuk çocuk
olmadı bugün dünyalar ve insanın
hayatını söndüren Ovit sadece payzer
şirketinin yıllık 15 milyar dolar para
kazanabilmesi için insanlık ölüme
Geçenlerde Güney Afrika ve Hindistan
dünya ticaret Örgütü'ne başvurdu ve en
azından annemi bitene kadar insan
ölürken katetti geçici süre maaşı
konusunda asker al
O bahçe dünyanın dört bir tarafında
Fabrikalar da üretirsin ve insanlar
olasın işte biliyor musunuz Devletleri
karşıtı diyebilirsiniz Amerika Avrupa
Birliği'nin temsilcileri karşılığı
demokrasi Adam dünya dediğimiz istemsiz
bir geç karşılıklı Hani Dünya Sağlık
Örgütü'ne Vakfı aracılığıyla yardım
yapıp yoksul ülkelere aşağı göndermeye
çalışan Bilge staj çıktı böyle
sermayenin tek bir amacı vardır Çok
yoksul Kalanları da biraz yardım yapar
iştahını verenlere kazancıda atladığımız
bir nokta var o aşıların keşfedilmesi
ve hükümetler Milyonlarca dolar o
firmalara bu şirketlere yardım ettiler
onlar sağladılar o paralar olmasaydı
Bugün o şirketten aşıları eş edemezdi
üretmezse salonları kimden aldı sizden
benden annenizden babanızdan vergiler
sayesinde bizim cebimizden çıkan
vergiler bir kuvvetler alıcıyla
şirketlerine onun olarak sağlandı şimdi
o aşılar o üretilen aşılar bizim
sahibimiz değil mi izin malımız değil mi
zaten onları bir yurttaşlara finanse
ettik Abla bu da o Dünyada yani adına
doğru söyleyelim akraba kal kapitalizmin
olduğu yerlerde insanlar eşittir Aha
insanlar daha eşittir midemizde yeterli
paranız varsa eğer etnik Köken
Ne oldu gene çoğunluktaysa erkekseniz
iseniz Bizim de üstündür bakın bunun
için İngiltere'de sırası gelmemiş 30
yaşında 40 yaşında zengin İngiliz
insanlarına indi standa ve dua ile
arasıyla yapılmaktadır Hindistan'da ki
bu milyarlarca insan aşağıya
ulaşılamazken 65 yaşın üstünde anne
Kronik hastalığı varken ulaşamaz Ken
İngilizce Sokak 30 yaşında gelin
değiştirince parası olduğu için tatil
yapmakta ve sonra aşık pasaportu
sağlayarak aşırı olmuş bir şekilde
Dünyanın her tarafında gezme hakkını
kaybetmekte gasp etti bu dünyaya aşağıya
ulaşamayan insanların da aşırı
pasaportuyla geçmesini sağlamaya
çalışmak Arkadaşlar şu Görmek zorundayız
bu dünyadaki süreç
bu devrimine başladı Fransız Devrimi çok
önemli bir değerinde hepimize Yurttaşlık
Hakkı saklıdır yasa karşısında eşitsiz
dedi Fransız Devriminin eksik bıraktığı
bir şey yasanın karşısında eksik o ve
eşit olmak hayatta eşit olmaya getirme
biliyoruz ki bu dünyada cebinde parası
olmak erkek olmak ağırlıklı o toplumun
etnik kökenden olmak o zaman başka bir
devrime ihtiyacımız var sadece yasa
karşısında eşit değil Toplumsal olarak
ve eşitlikçi bu dünyanın dört bir
yanındaki herkese eşit gören bir başka
devrime ihtiyacı var eşitsizlik bir
karar değildir bir eşitsizlik tarih
boyunca dayım her zaman var değildir bir
sessizlik tarihte sınıflı toplumlarda
ortaya çıkmıştır bir yerden ülke varsa
bir yerde sermaye
da bir yerde kar varsa orada
eşitlikçilik yapıp olamaz tarihin ve
kainatın bakın sınıflı toplumlarda önce
toplumlar eşittir bir görev paylaşımı
vardı ama komünal şimdi bugün Hani
dağlarındaki otsu Kumandan tam arkası
dediğim gibi sözümüz silahımızdır yok ki
bize bir tane ayrımız var bu Hayır
diyoruz Evet biz çok farklı kadınların
nöbeti emekçinin nöbeti ekmek cinsiyeti
farklı olanın cinsel yönelim farklı
olanın lgbt artıların her birinin Evet
farklı ama ekle Hayır hayır demek
zorundayız yaşamımız için bu dünyadaki
doğanın hayvan dostlarımız için bir
başka devrimi var bu sürecin bir parçası
olacak
Sen Benim Alın yalnız değilsiniz bu
dünyada bunun kavgasını yürütenler vardı
Yarın da sizden sonra da var olacaktır
deli gibi yok edin insanın insana
kullana bizim daveti tarih boyunca hep
birlikte süreceğiz teşekkür ederim